his dirt and he's ugly he's an [ __ ] I
think he's the most sexist man alive no
no because he [ __ ] sucks wonderful
[ __ ] you do you know who Andrew Tay is
yeah do you like him
not really why I don't know him like
that well yeah I know but like from like
the Social Media stuff do you like him
um not really I think like the [ __ ] he
says is a joke oh like look I think he's
like I think he's like putting on an act
oh you think so yeah I don't think
that's like real like I think he does it
for attention there's no reason to do
for attention if he's already banned on
everything okay yeah but but like why
don't you like him this is misogynistic
can you define misogyny for me
what the [ __ ] do you know who Andrew Tay
is
do you know what Andrew Tate is uh yeah
do you like him oh watch out for that
fresh air
why are you asking me that no I'm just
I'm sorry you're asking me that okay
yeah so why don't you like them why are
you asking I was wondering just just
smack her in the face with that spoon
okay okay
she couldn't think of a lie the that man
can do all these things and women can't
and like men have to protect women and
you think you think the woman should
protect the men I think that they can
protect each other I know women plenty
of women that are stronger than me yeah
so do I dude that's not saying a lot
just because you can't do a push-up
doesn't mean that men shouldn't be
protecting women ah these people man
people oh yeah I know but I'm just
saying
okay my Andrew Tate is yeah
huh yeah do you like them no why no
I'm good
why I don't have the strong enough
opinion to you don't have a strong
enough opinion you just said you don't
like him
so why don't you like him you said you
don't like them and you don't have an
opinion on them so why come to the
conclusion to not like him she's a sheep
because about him because I've watched
it doesn't change.org headlines but
as you follow what the media says
yes I will wear my mask
I will wear my mask I will get my fourth
booster okay I have one more question
why don't you like them
because he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] well my
question is why don't you like him
because he's misogynistic [ __ ] here
okay Define misogynist women he didn't
though he did though no you're giving
him way too much
permission like he's my uncle
that's why well you know I hope he
spends a lot of time in jail and I hope
he gets every day in the shower
wonderful
oh what a loving what a loving human
calling other people [ __ ] this this
one here did he just say that he she
said he hopes are you wearing that he
hopes that yeah every day in the shower
like come on these people are the
biggest Hypocrites ever the biggest
hippo he didn't no we don't know that
he's a hypocrite he may be hateful to
everybody he just may be a big hateful
Beast who knows yeah but they're the
same ones that advocate for peace and
then they go out and they don't know
that this person is they are this is
this person is clearly listen that
particular person is clearly yeah yeah
you're right dude he's my uncle you're
not supposed to say that
yeah do you like them no why
I just think he says a lot of
misogynistic stuff Define misogyny look
at the camera she bet you know what's
up you know could the library to look at
this message can you name what is
misogyny like what is actual misogyny I
don't I mean I I don't know what a real
definition not like
no I don't know I I I'm looking for the
answer you know I know it has it's
generally and I I can't Define
microphone properly like you know it's
very I got to be honest asking somebody
what's the definition of this or that is
difficult yeah but if you're gonna call
someone a massage right you should at
least be able to have a roundabout
description of what it is if she is so
uh my understanding is it's um you know
the idea of men treating women poorly in
some way like I can't even really Define
it but again I can't Define just about
anything words that I know how to use
and I know what they mean look it up
just just look it up let's do it right
now please I need to know misogyny
definition right there [ __ ]
dislike or contempt for or brains
prejudice against women okay I guess
that's like the same thing as racism it
probably says the same thing just for
against a certain race but you know you
can't be racist against white grains
prejudice against what or just like for
women okay that makes sense and it's
funny because it didn't have the new
ones that I thought it had which is more
like active microaggression type of
behavior act you know actively showing
microaggressions so there's a difference
between having a dislike for women and
showing a dislike for women so I kind of
thought it was more showing it but uh
you know where we all just learned
something look at that Andrew Tate
misogynist and she's just stuck with
that there's this guy he helped someone
overcome
okay do you feel like that's a good
thing to do I would think so you would
think so I would think yeah
he helped that person not commit
what are your opinions on Andrew Tate I
don't like that guy why
I mean the [ __ ] he said about women
isn't he like
what is it
isn't he charging Romania for sex
trafficking no
no you sure about that yeah charges were
dropped
his house was raised at least she's
she's not coming at this as uh he was
he's a sex trafficker she's asking
what's the question she goes wasn't he
like or yeah she's actually being you
know somewhat reasonable and
acknowledging by her by her tone that
she doesn't know everything okay well
change your views on them still
still
corrected
can I get a reason
there's enough
not one reason was said do you know who
Andrew Tate is yes I do do you like him
no why I should do this video this would
be funny misogynistic and like his views
are so like they're so extreme right
they find misogyny for me
um the
damn yeah you got me no but she knows
what it means you know what again asking
doing that to somebody is just being a
um like a let me you know stump the
sucker kind of a thing you know and it's
not nice and it's foolish and it
actually doesn't solve anything I think
he'd be much more effective if he said
okay can you just give me one specific
example he said you've heard from him
that upset you or that you disagreed
with that would be far more effective I
still think you should these people
should be able to say like at least a
sentence I feel like you should do this
stuff and I know what it means like I
and I know how to use the word properly
he's a misogynist but you know he's a
four-time world champion yeah I do know
that okay so you want to let him fight
for you no you'd rather just get beat
get jumped really yeah you hate him that
much yeah this is going to be the most
critical question you're gonna get asked
today so think
think before you say anything okay do
you know who Andrew Tate is
yes do you like him [ __ ] now why because
he [ __ ] sucks
okay that's not a reason dude do you
have a reason why you don't like him
he's an misogynist Define misogyny I'm
not [ __ ] doing this what's wrong
what's happening most important question
of the day
okay do you know who Andrew say is
unfortunately
do you like them why would I like him
why wouldn't you not like him he just
has a lot of misogynistic things like
from what I've seen it's just like women
belong at the kitchen and I'm not a
woman belonging the kitchen type of girl
oh yeah okay all right that's honestly
honestly fair point because it's not her
fault she's not a critical thinker she
wasn't raised to be a critical thinker
because that's how the school system
teaches them to be to teach them just
read oh just were you feeling Tick Tock
that's what it is it'll teach you to
think too deep inish anymore so when
everything he's like that's portrayed
about him is taken out of context then
yeah I can kind of understand why they
wouldn't like him yeah that's the most
things taken out of context that's the
problem though is and everything even if
you see something that you agree with
that feeds your narrative that is like
perfect Echo chamber stuff for you turn
around and say is this true and dig a
Little Deeper because it's still maybe
out of context and you may be being
[ __ ] you may be being lied to by
somebody that knows that you're going to
agree with something so I I was talking
to a good friend of mine today who's
who's gay and a gay marriage long-term
gay marriage and talking because we're
moving you're friends with a gay person
don't be a [ __ ] you know I'm saying
talking about Florida and every time we
talk about them visiting me in Florida
he kind of crunches and I go what what
what's the matter what do you think is
going to happen to you in Florida
Florida is not like the land of the
anti-gay and he's like I hate Ron
DeSantis and I was like okay why and he
said because of the don't say gay law oh
my gosh relax I'm not [ __ ] on my
phone okay all right and we're not
[ __ ] on him here because I love him
first okay and what my point is is that
I said listen that law doesn't say that
and the law I said there's the word gay
doesn't even appear in the law and he
goes yes it does I go no have you read
it he goes no I said it doesn't appear I
said the news is trying to demonize him
for because what he did was created a
law that there will be no sex education
be up to the third grade so we can't
talk about transgenders gay
relationships heterosexual relationships
which is quote unquote traditional we're
not talking about any of that we're
talking about Reading Writing math
science up to that the third grade
that's it and if relationships come up
and a kid talks about a gay couple that
he knows that he can ask the teacher and
the teacher can address it and then move
on but it's not going to be part of the
curriculum so and he was very surprised
to hear that because he has only been
listening to one side of the news and
something that feeds his narrative that
Republicans are bad and I and I don't
know if he believed me or not but I said
Luke if you don't believe me read the
book out and I can't encourage everybody
enough again he is a guy who's so
intelligent great job great life great
everything and taking in news and just
believing it we got to stop doing that
we have to start asking questions what's
that supposed to mean real quick real
quick it's okay it's okay let me see a
trick
yeah you were right URS
can I ask you a question real quick
okay do you know who Andrew Tate is
uh
yeah I mean okay uh what are your
opinions on them
did you like them it's creepy no
no why because he's a misogynist
can you give me a good reason why I
don't like them the same reason I said
[Music]
but that's just what the media says
have you really like saw his clips and
yeah
okay see our fan no
no I don't like him because he's a
misogynist okay all right do you know
what Angie Tate is Andrew Tate yeah
the
the podcast person yeah he has a podcast
yeah do you like him no why
misogynist
what you're like the 100th person to say
that today can you give me a good reason
why I don't like him other than misogyny
who watches podcast so oh so you don't
watch them
anyway
um like clips that I've seen what'd you
see
I don't know do you guys know who Andrew
Tate is yes you like them surprise wait
why because he's a misogynist they find
misogyny he's a dirt and he's ugly and
um he abuses and beats woman but he
thinks he's better is it because that
video
it's close to all the videos because of
how he talks about women he loves women
though no he doesn't he he says women
secretly he's gay yeah why because what
do you mean by that they always say this
but what do you mean by that as if it's
like what do you mean by that okay go
into it yeah I'm just like they always
say that like it's an insult that's why
I wanted what I'm saying because maybe
it's that maybe they're just saying he
is just projecting because he doesn't
want to acknowledge who he really is
yeah does that make sense yeah and I
think that's kind of where they're
coming from even though they're saying
it in a in a shitty way I don't think
[ __ ] man I don't think they're actually
trying to insult the case
[Music]